no jce no peace no justice no peace no
jce say his
name say his name say her
name say
her 57 years ago in
1963 in the middle of struggle and
murder they came to Washington to demand
for civil rights act and voting
rights it's very important for me to be
here today I was here in
1963 I was 14 years of age when I
listened to Martin Luther King gave his
speech and look at the hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of people that
look like me from all Works life could
gather
peacefully they gave me Insight that
anything is possible if you apply
yourself and that no voice should be
[Applause]
solid because they came in
63 we were able to come back in
2020 in the midst of a
pandemic we want to come to show without
bades that enough is
enough the March then was really
important for things like voting rights
and
accountability and unfortunately this is
about voting rights it's about
accountability if you replace lynching
with laying on somebody's neck that's
the same
thing and so here we are you know 57
years later and we're still talking
about the same issues
I wasn't here back in the day when the
original March came but there was a
tragic accident that happened in our
neighborhood with my son's best friend
so I felt like the awareness that we
were getting locally has now became
National and I want to be supportive of
that and who was your son's best friend
Amad Aubrey he's the gentleman on my
t-shirt
imagine a small
town and imagine a black family inside
there a black family who is reminded
daily that they are different from
others they're not seen in the same way
as others turn around put your hands on
the car turn around put your hands on
the car I'm checking you for we checking
for weapons who understand that the
threats that exist around them take
place from a variety of different
forms some
structural some with authority and power
hand out your pocket hands out your
pocket pocket and it's something that
parents have been
telling and teaching and drilling into
their children not because of a measure
of
paranoia but is a measure of
protection imagine walking through those
streets constantly having to look around
for
something that might bring you harm and
knowing that it might show itself in
different ways and different
days and that the way you have to
navigate the
world the way you have to navigate your
daily
existence is with a core goal of simple
survival 911 was the address your
emergency I'm not here shores as a black
mail running down the street where where
where at shes know
what and imagine when on that
Journey at that moment when you start
feeling
LAX at that moment when you start
feeling maybe I was thinking about it
too
much maybe this isn't a big
deal that moment when you're
reminded about why people warned you in
the first
place
stop
it sir hello
sir
about why it was so important to teach
you
early that your existence is not going
to be welcomed by
everybody the combination of video and
statements from the suspects have
painted a clear picture that Aubry was
hunted down and ultimately
executed that's Glen County
Georgia that's many areas around this
[Music]
country
you have in fact after emancipation the
rise of vigilante groups the klut clan
the Knights of the white Chamas they had
different names in different places and
they saw it as their job to intimidate
and keep black people in their
place it's much like today we talk about
the Karens you know who have feel called
upon when they see some black person
doing some routine thing that they think
is out of the way or they shouldn't be
doing it that they should take it upon
themselves to impose a kind of order in
addition to what ordinary law
enforcement people who were official
were doing there is an African-American
man I in se he is recording me and
threatening myself and my
dog please send the cops to me
and emit till was the most notorious
example emit till was a young boy from
Chicago he was 14 years old and as The
Story Goes he whistled at a white
woman and that night these white
rednecks they murdered him
and his mother decided to have an open
casket so everybody could view what
happened to her
son but that's the way it was in those
days if you even looked at a white woman
in the South you could lose your
[Music]
life that was the first time I had
firsthand knowledge and experience with
the Jim Crow
South the clue clux Clan
the
lynchings just trying to imagine what it
was like living under those
conditions this made you
angry this showed you the force of the
Vigilante as a a reinforcement of the
law and with am at aubury the same kind
of thing happened okay if you were to
stopped this that's fine that's F and
this kind of behavior is no different
from what happened to black people
earlier in all kinds of
situations and so you would think that
the law would be on your
side and the effort of the Civil Rights
Movement was to try to get the law to be
on our side to fulfill the promises as
they put it of the Declaration of
Independence and of the Constitution the
language that was there but for
everybody and not just for some
people but and of course in ' 63 we had
Birmingham dogs biting
people women and
children not college students but young
children 10 years old 9 years old 8
years old who out there are protesting
it was night after night Vivid graphic
images which were
[Music]
undeniable there were also police had
long used the tactic of when they
grabbed somebody that they wanted to
stop or harass they would push them down
and then they would put their knee on
the person's neck to hold them down see
to make them submit to their power
fighting just for myself
no and these very brutal images which
the president couldn't deny because no
one else could deny it because you saw
it with your own eyes made it possible
for the movement to go
[Applause]
forward and so the civil rights leaders
decided that we should have a March on
Washington
we are requesting all citizens to move
into Washington to go by plane by car
bus any way that you can get there walk
if necessary we are pushing for jobs
housing desegregated schools this is an
urgent request please join go to
Washington I got there early I was right
in front of the Lincoln Memorial where I
could see the entire
crowd was awesome looking at
that and to see so many white people in
the struggle was
encouraging it seemed like the movement
was reaching a pinnacle who is our
leader Dr Who is our leader
Dr Martin Luther King was on television
quite a bit he was beginning to emerge
as a
leader and he was an eloquent speaker
any blisters yet well no blisters yet
but uh my legs are a little tired but I
can follow that up by saying that my
soul is
rested on the 28th of August
1963 we took the train from New York to
Washington there's a photograph of me
and my family at the March and I'm
holding a sign that says no more Us St
to help Jim Crow grow and this was about
you know the African-Americans who
needed the economic freedom and the the
freedom from police
brutality and all of the issues that
were afflicting black people in America
at that time that we could see every
night on
television most people remember the
march in Washington but remembering that
I Have a Dream speech from B Luther King
but there was so much more to it than
that there are those who are asking the
devotes of civil
rights when will you be
satisfied we can never be satisfied as
long as the Negro is the victim of the
Unspeakable horrors of least brutality
we will not be satisfied until Justice
rolls down like Waters and righteousness
like a mighty
scam I mean that was the whole tone and
tenor of the part of his speech that
people don't often pay any attention to
and the reason why they don't is because
it's too
painful because it's too
obvious but the most important part of
his speech was the part when he said
that we've come to
Washington to cash a check that will
give us freedom and Justice so we can
benefit from the law on
demand but we are told that the bank of
justice is
bankrupt and we've been given back this
check marked insufficient
funds it is obvious
today that America has defaulted on this
promisory note in so far as her citizens
of color are concerned America has given
the Negro people a bad check it's the
greatest speech of my lifetime and I'm
63 years old free at last free at last
thank God Almighty we are free at
[Applause]
last we shall over
[Music]
am I would simply like to say that I
think this has been one of the great
days of America and I think this March
will go down as one of the greatest if
not the greatest uh demonstrations for
freedom and human dignity ever held in
the United
States fre
fre
despite the fact that the March was a
success in terms of what they wanted to
do the image that they wanted to show
the violence continued and the inability
to get protection of the law
[Music]
continued we know that the 16th Street
Baptist Church where the four little
girls were killed that that
happened we'll be demonstrating here
until Freedom comes to Negroes here in
Jackson Mississippi so similar to when
Medgar Evers who was the head of the
state nacp in Mississippi was shot and
killed in his own
[Music]
driveway why vigilantism involved in it
so that the vigilantism did not
subside and I think it gave strength to
the cause that resulted in the Civil
Rights Act in ' 64 the Voting Rights Act
in '
65 honestly if you look at it the
protesters who marged during the Civil
Rights Movement were often labeled as
troublemakers criminals and this was
part of Martin Luther King's philosophy
if the rest of the country could see how
things are down south perhaps they will
be sympathetic to our movement But
ultimately um did it make any difference
I have some very sad news for all of you
and I think uh sad news for all of our
fellow
citizens and people who love peace all
over the world and that is that Martin
Luther King was shot and was killed
tonight in
[Applause]
[Music]
Memphis I ask every
citizen to reject the blind
violence that has struck Dr
King who lived by
[Music]
[Applause]
nonviolence Senator Kennedy has been
shot is that possible is that possible
oh my God Senator Kennedy has been
shot Martin Luther King and Bobby
Kennedy were
murdered within you know a few few
months time the heroes of this movement
were gunned down it was just
shattering I think we were all afraid
that something else was going to happen
there was that constant fear that some
other crazy person would do something
terrible the frustration would result in
a different type of activism the of the
nobility of non-violent protest Civil
Disobedience that came very much into
question it looked like you know it was
time to fight back and many people
[Applause]
[Music]
did the issues that were being
discussed at the 1963 March and
thereafter have never really been
resolved and so every time there's some
protest you will hear about the same
issues even after we had the civil
rights movement and we got laws
passed the problems of jobs and the
problem of freedom and the problems of
communities and education and all the
things that people have been fighting
for and the law not on your
side was perpetuated it it didn't end as
a result America's Public Enemy Number
One in the United States is drug
abuse in order to fight and defeat this
enemy it is necessary to wage a new
allout
offensive the whole War on Drugs is a
euphemism to let lock up anybody in the
black community that's associated with
drugs and give them the longest sentence
we can
concoct in this Administration we have
increased the amount of money for
handling the problem of dangerous drugs
Sevenfold it will be $600 million this
year Richard Nixon created these
regressive drug laws he increased the
number of police in the black community
fourfold and he was the first during the
50s and 60s to put on Supreme Court
Justices who would agree with his
approach to the black community as you
know one of the most critical duties
that we faced upon taking office was
controlling the influx of illegal drugs
into this country the next bad actor was
Ronald
Reagan Ronald Reagan quadrupled the
number of blacks imprisoned in the
criminal justice
system and mass incarceration put the
cap on what was a progressing community
and put it into a community that is
spiraling out of control towards the
abyss and so if that is an Institutional
racism I don't know what is all right
everybody turn
around break out some ID we were hearing
and seeing images of black men selling
drugs black men going to jail and we had
all heard that statistic how the number
one cause a death for black men was
homicide this the prognosis for black
men in general was just not very
good the image of many black men during
this time was a stereotypical image
associated with drug dealers perhaps
drug users in some context built on
images of the black man as a minister to
society as someone to be feared and so I
think it cast the black man in a
negative light and made him into in many
ways a
[Music]
monster back in 1991 when history was
created when I filmed what I filmed with
this camera we woke up in the middle of
the night with the noise of the
helicopter that was super low right
outside our apartment all the police car
pulling up with their sirens bluring and
uh the first thing I thought of is pick
up the
camera and then the the rest is is
history I
guess neighborhoods erupted with anger
after four white LA police officers were
acquitted of assaulting motorist Rodney
King and what I saw was a gentleman on
the floor struggling trying to get up
and he was being beaten by some police
officers with their uh
batons
you could even hear the batons hitting
him and I'm not sure if I was
aware whether he was African-American or
not I mean it to me it was a human being
and he was being hit and that didn't
seem right to me it was not
right so after the Rodney King verdict
and the officers were acquitted the
riots in Los Angeles began and would
become a integral part of American
history
[Music]
more than 35 people have died more than
3,000 people are under arrest the police
and the National Guard do not yet have
the city completely under their
[Music]
control kicking the driver and beating
the driver they're attacking everyone
that comes to a stop here at this
[Music]
intersection and so some people decide
well well if you are not going to hear
us we're going to make you hear
[Music]
us it's kind of like if I can't run it
I'm going to wreck it I tried to go
through the system and that didn't work
so now I'm about to tear some
up now pulling the door off the car
don't want to come down
here you know the idea of of people
saying well why would you burn down your
own neighborhood or or that argument
that gets made out the reality is when
people are so angry and frustrated and
frankly feeling so silenced it's
difficult to hear from other people how
I should protest my
[Music]
oppression often times people think that
Justice or these movements have been
about a singular thing right that it's
been it's been Justice for for for jobs
or it's been Justice about policing and
police brutality or it's been Justice
For Better schools no it's
Justice it's Justice and that promise
inside of this nation is something that
is not a given for
everybody
[Applause]
Senator Obama the Nobel prize-winning
africanamerican author Tony Morrison
famously observed about Bill Clinton
quote this is our first black president
blacker than any actual black person who
could ever be elected in our children's
lifetime do you think Bill Clinton was
our first black
[Applause]
president
well
um in Comes This Governor Bill Clinton
who when he showed up on the Arenal Hall
Show and he started playing the
saxophone and he was comfortable in that
environment
it felt as if he was a a black man I was
in South Central LA three years before
the riot occurred I met with a dozen
sixth graders about my daughter's age
who told me their biggest fear in life
was being shot going to in from school
Clinton looked as if he
cared and that is what Tony Morrison was
speaking about which is why in hindsight
when when you look at his actual
policies you realize that he may
personally have been for us but
legislatively he did some things that
were very much against us particularly
when it comes to his support of the 1994
crime bill which gutted the black
community in a lot of different
ways he said nobody's going to be harder
on crime and criminals than
me his almost exact words well who would
the what was the crime who were the
criminals he wasn't talking about white
collar criminals he talking about
us one of the most damning part of the
1994 crime bill was that three strike
rule whereas if you accumulated you know
three felonies for instance regardless
of the degrees or regardless if they
were violent or not you could have been
in prisoned for the rest of your life
literally white folks had their and
figuratively they had their foot on
next as much as I
enjoyed the Clinton years with the
campaign and eventual election of
President Obama it was a great
achievement for people of color all
around the
globe and with that came Great
Expectations and
hope ladies and gentlemen the next
family united stat
stes the election of Barack Obama was in
some ways the most exhilarating thing
that could have happened in the black
community the
symbolism was absolutely significant and
important and many people held out hope
that now at last we won't have these you
know shootings unarmed people and none
of of this stuff will happen again oh
Glory Hallelujah and some people said
well maybe he'll even put the red green
and black flag up next to the other flag
at the White House this election had
many firsts and many stories that will
be told for Generations but one that's
on my mind tonight's about a woman who
cast her ballot in Atlanta she was there
for the buses in Montgomery the hoses in
Birmingham a bridge in Selma and a
preacher from Atlanta who told the
people that we shall overcome
yes we can yes we can change has come to
America so it was
hope but that soon sort of
dissipated Trayvon Martin an unarmed
black teenager was shot down by a white
neighborhood Watchman who claimed
self-defense and had has not at this
point been
[Music]
arrested I felt his arm going down to my
side and I grabbed it and I just grabbed
my firearm and I shot him and he said
you got
me you got it you got me so people
enjoyed the mere presence of Barack
Obama and the fact that he was
president but when Dyan rof went into
that church in Charleston then killed
all those
people it was exactly what happened in
16th Street Baptist Church in 63 when
the little girls were
killed kids were
murdered in
Birmingham on a Sunday and in Sunday
School in a Christian Nation and nobody
[Applause]
cares the same kind of
vigilantism
[Music]
the fact that this took place uh in a
black church obviously also raises
questions about a dark part of our
history this is not the first time that
black churches have been
attacked what people were hoping for was
a signal that the old order has changed
none of this can happen
anymore because now we have a black
president
he was put in the very same impossible
position of being expected to clean up
all of the sins of the
past the phrase postracial started
emerging everywhere like white people
started congratulating themselves look
what we did we killed racism there's a
black man in the white house
now but it really didn't turn out to be
as miraculous as as everyone hoped it
would
[Music]
be Corona virus is killing more
African-Americans than any other group
of people in the United
States almost 60% % of coron virus
deaths when we all got news about the
pandemic in March we saw pretty quickly
how for black and brown communities
black folks specifically that black
folks were dying at the highest rates
had the least amount of Access to Health
Care and also live with
multigenerational people that were also
imuno
compromised and just when we thought
things couldn't get
worse me see your
hands Dam man the car let me see your
other hand I'm Sor I'm sorry let me see
your George Floyd
happened step out and face away step out
and face away please don't shoot me
please man I'm not going to shoot you
step out and face away I'm looking you
out eye man please don't shoot
me I just was my mom
man get the
wall yes what I doing we're figuring out
what's going on drop the
bag figure out what's going
okay you're
[Applause]
talking I man I can't breathe I'm not
bad guy man in the car I'm not a bad
gu please please let me
stande man I can't breathe I can't
breath shut up
me give me
man well you should check on him he's
not
responsive not responsive right now
bro
and they killed
him want one of us ride with yeah
with we certainly had seen cruel things
that were caught on video
before but I think the images that I saw
of that police officer who was
kneeling on George Floyd it looked like
it was just a Tuesday to him he did not
look like somebody who was murdering
somebody in front of everybody else and
you not only look at him but then you
think about the other officers that are
around and it's just a Tuesday for them
too no big deal and I think just the the
ease in which they did it is what
probably stun
people thousands gathered for an
emotional farewell to George Floyd
George Floyd's story has been the story
of black folks the reason we could never
be who we wanted and dreamed to be in is
you kept your knee on our
neck therefore on August 28th the 57th
anniversary of the March on Washington
we going back to Washington
Martin we need to go back to Washington
and stand up and tell them this is the
time to stop
this good afternoon we want to take you
right now to the nation's capital where
thousands of protesters have gathered
and are channeling words spoken by Dr
Martin Luther King Jr 57 years ago
during his I Have a Dream
speech the 2020 March on Washington has
been dubbed the get your knee off our
next
march the best and the brightest of the
white Community were absolutely in their
outrage about what they
saw this is brand
new I applaud them that's what the white
community's role should have always been
when you look at the collection of
events that people had to deal with this
year on top of it being a pandemic you
can easily see why this felt like
something that was worth whatever risk
they thought that they were uh
sacrificing I mean historically there
were many incidents where we'd
experienced and seeing death and Trauma
I do have a firearm on don't reach for
it P don't pull
[Applause]
so I think there was just this idea that
if you were a black man your time on
this Earth was very limited and more
than likely the time that you spent on
this Earth was very violent can't can't
17-year-old laquan McDonald shot 16
times in a matter of 15 seconds 16 shots
16 shots 16 shots the truth of what
happened to Walter Scott is only coming
to life because someone in the bushes
was recording with a camera on a cell
phone you threatening to drag me out of
my own car get out of the car I will
light you up get out wow now Sandra
Bland pinned to the ground and screaming
she's a victim of excessive
force 3 days later she was found dead
hanging in her
cell mom get back Mom Mom Mom you have
to get
[Applause]
back let me see your other hands both
hands put your hands up right now let me
see your other hand M
Mama I'm mad as
hell I'm tired of seeing black men die
Mama I love you re I love you you got h
get my
11 when a man yells for his mother and
she's dead he is essentially yelling
please God don't let it happen to me and
we watch that over and over again so
that's why I think when we think about
why do we have a collective sense of of
movement momentum uh it's because what
we saw with Mr George Floyd wasn't that
it was a singular incident right it was
the fact that his name name was now
being added to a much longer list a much
longer lineage of people who have died
who have been killed and there has been
no accountability for it that his name
now gets added to a list that includes
Michael Brown and fando
Castile and lacoin McDonald and Sandra
Bland and bana Taylor and Anthony
Anderson and Chris Brown and Freddy gray
and Walter Scott and Eric Gardner and
Trayvon Martin and the list goes on and
on and on and so the argument and the
demand is that there has to be a greater
accountability and
acknowledgment of black
life and that that is not just simply
about policing either whether we're
talking about the marches of the 60s or
the marches that are taking place right
now that's what the marches are about
out it's about changing
systems I have the feeling that the
Negroes we've been held down so long
that if people don't fight now by the
time they do be nothing here to fight
for
us tens of thousands of people made
their way to Washington DC because it
was that important to
them Dr King's first idea was not
necessarily to have a big March in
Washington but to have lots of
birminghams across the country and in
many respects the summer of 2020
reflected that
Vision New York Chicago Detroit Los
Angeles San Francisco all these cities
with streets filled with young
people we're
tired like we are so tired of just being
hurt you bought us here now we here live
with us deal with us help
us I'm living off the interest of Dr
King the late great John Lewis they
stood and protested so I can be here and
that I am forever grateful
due to the pandemic we all determined
that it was important enough for us to
calm cuz we realize if we don't affect
change that the pandemic May kill us but
it'll kill us
peacefully
[Music]
matter I hear
[Applause]
you we now have black lives matter Plaza
we have all kinds of other marches but
even after the pandemic is over if we
don't do something we'll be back here
you know over and over
again and we're not going to stop
disrupting and are
you I like
that
be no justice now we going to shut it
all
down it all down it
it we don't get no justice now we don't
get no justice now we going to shut it
all down we going to shut it
all it all start it all down to start it
all down we going to start it all down
[Music]
[Applause]
it
my grandfather was the first black
minister in the history of the Dutch
reform church but he used to tell the
parable about Moses where Moses marched
the Israelites up
to the River Jordan and came up as to
the banks and you know for decades and
decades he marched and he toiled and he
brought his people and finally he gets
to this promised land and the river
parts for him to be able to lead his
people
through
and God tells
him wonderful job your time is up and
I'm going to ask Joshua to take it from
here and he used to tell this story
about how he imagined Moses's
frustration with that where he's like I
did all the hard
work and God essentially tells him no
because that's someone else's
job and I think about that in context of
this
moment where none of us are asked to do
everything but all of us are asked to do
something and understand that the next
person will do their job and the next
person will do their job and when your
time is done and you pass that baton to
the next person
that you literally have nothing
left that we are here because people ran
as hard as they
could and then they handed the Baton to
[Music]
us